aujourd'hui séance de tractage pour le
parti animalistes devant la gare de
poissy l'occasion pour les candidats
civils loi de faire connaître ce
mouvement politique créé en 2016 et qui
compte plus de 400 candidats inscrits
aux élections législatives cette année
dans toute la france les partis
politiques classiques disent on ne
prennent pas suffisamment au sérieux la
cause animale la question animale et
qu'il faut vraiment visibiliser un
électorat pour lequel la cause animale
est vraiment essentiel son terrain
politique au total douze candidats
seront présents sur l'ensemble des
circonscriptions yvelinoise dans son
projet le parti veut notamment interdire
la chasse et la chasse à courre on a
aujourd'hui en fait l'homme continue je
dis si bien l'homme est pas l'humain je
pense que ses hommes ont perdu leur
humanité donc ces hommes en fait
continuer à interpréter idées à
perpétrer des des traditions absolument
cruel dans quel monde vit-on
peut-on encore parler de deux personnes
civilisées lorsqu'on pratique encore des
choses aussi barbare une autre mesure
phare concerne les conditions dans les
abattoirs en réponse notamment aux
images de maltraitance animale diffusé
en 2017 par l'association l214 dans cet
abattoir à houdan comporte comme
proposition d'installer des caméras de
vidéosurveillance dans les abattoirs
choses qui avaient été promises mais qui
n'a malheureusement jamais été fait un
parent par les pouvoirs publics et on
souhaite également entre autres
instauré l'obligation d'abattage avec
étourdissement en 2017 le parti
animalistes étaient présents dans deux
circonscriptions et avait recueilli un
peu plus de 1% des suffrages pendant les
élections législatives cette année les
candidats espèrent atteindre les 4% sur
l'ensemble du département